[Music]
welcome people now let's continue with
the next set of games
uh because it seems like
people are pretty clear okay let's go
for 1300 and again let's go e5
beginners can play the sicilian although
well i'll talk more about that afterward
and he played the king's gambit i know a
lot of people are anxious to see how i
play against
the king's cabin now there's a couple of
very interesting options um against the
king's gambit that i can recommend to
beginners but
right now i want to play a variation
that
illustrates uh the sort of the the point
of the king's gamut and
various ways we have of playing against
now the best thing i like to do against
the king's gambit that i would recommend
to beginners
is to take the pawn and then play d5
what is the purpose of the move d5 the
purpose of the move d5 is very simple
by playing f4 white has weakened his
king side right i mean
everybody would agree with me on that
and by our
principle when our opponent weakens his
king side we want to generally open up
the center in order to beat more
in order to be able to exploit that but
we don't want to take this pawn
immediately with our queen
because as we know we allow the move
knight c3 uh
which kicks the queen and increases
white's lead in development
so we're going to play knight f6 here
and try to take that pawn with our
knight which has two effects first of
all we keep our queen safe second of all
we actually lend support to that f4 pawn
by taking with the knight
so he plays d4 that is a very typical
mistake knight takes d5
and he cannot take the pawn with his
bishop now he continues to develop his
pieces
naturally that makes sense but we're
going to do the same thing
right we're just going to play bishop e7
uh which some people might
consider to be a passive move but
remember we are upon up
right i don't need to develop in a
particularly active manner
you might be looking at this and saying
well wait a second he could have taken
on d5 and then taken on f4 couldn't he
have won the pawn back
what the hell are you doing daniel well
i will explain that after the game in
fact
this is in the same theme as the last
game we are transforming our advantage i
am willing to sacrifice back the pawn
that is why the king's gamut is not as
effective as people used to think
because black can essentially sack the
pawn back in many lines
and gain in return a set of positional
advantages
now uh a question for you guys how do we
take the sting
out of this bishop on c4 it's annoying
the hell out of me i don't like the fact
that it's x-raying my knight
i don't like the fact that there's
pressure on f7 what's a good way to just
prevent that from happening
no definitely not knight e3 that helps
him knight e3 helps him right it
actually helps him reinforce
the pressure so we're going to go bishop
e6 a typical development move
taking the sting out of his bishop and
uh
asking him what he wants to do no he can
absolutely win the pawn back right he
can take our knight and then he can take
it upon but what are we going to have in
return
for that pawn well we're going to have
first and foremost the two bishops in
beyond whatever we'll talk about that
after the game thank you once happens
now um the time has come for us to
contest his control over the center
and there's several ways for us to do
that
can somebody suggest for me a couple of
interesting
moves there's many things that we could
do here really many now c5
uh is my initial inclination but i
actually have stopped liking
it and i promise to explain why that is
after the game but basically he has c4
in return
so what we're gonna do instead is we're
going to play knight c6 this is a very
this is a five head move
okay because what i know some people are
thinking
why are you why are you making this move
why are you ruining your own pot
structure like what are you doing
uh and i will explain this that's the
purpose of the speed run okay
but basically we are going to use these
c pawns as a bargaining chip right now
the c bonds look bad
but in reality they're not bad at all
they can actually be pushed forward
one after the other and they can be used
to contest white's control over the
center
okay i know that that's a bit of a vague
explanation
uh but i will delve more deeply into
this after the game we are a little bit
short of
time okay so we see c5 now here's the
thing
if he takes our pawn on c5 that first
spot is going to be
replaced by another one and now watch
what happens watch very very carefully
what i do i take the bishop
now i will take the pawn on d4 with my
queen
and once he takes my queen and i take
with the pawn i have magically corrected
my pawn structure
and that pawn on c7 remember what i said
the fact that the pawns are doubled can
be a good thing because eventually we
might get a situation
where i've undoubled the pawns and the i
have another part of the c file that can
be used
to support its neighbor on d4 i've got
an extra pawn we are in an end game
i know some people wanted me to get end
games so here we go
what do we do in end games like these
first and foremost we need to activate
our pieces we need to make our pieces
the best that they can be so where
should this bishop go in order to be the
best that it can be
yes indeed the second thing that we need
to make sure of
is that his pieces do not get to active
squares this is the part people forget
this knight on f3 where does it want to
go
where does it want to go what active
square does it want to reach and how do
we stop it
from reaching that active square that's
all the prophylactic yeah
f6 that's all prophylaxis is and you
guys can find it
we go f6 and we stop his knight from
centralizing on e5
in fact robert hess uh my partner in
crime he pay
he sort of draws attention to this all
the time the fact that we have a pawn
that is essentially two open squares
away from the night
that is a very good situation for the
pawn okay
we're going to drive our opponent crazy
he wants to go to f5 that is very clear
from his last move
can we prevent him from coming to f5
with either the knight or the bishop
i will explain everything after the game
absolutely we can let's drive them
insane we go g6 right
and this kind of boa constrictor play is
what people hate to see
right and this is what people don't do
enough of
they get they get fixated on their own
ideas and they don't stop to ask
themselves what their opponent's idea is
when you do that
uh you often play moves like g6 and he's
out of ideas
let's continue in the same style he
wants to push this pawn and expand on
the queen side can we stop
him from doing that too even though it's
not necessary
can we just play in the same spirit yeah
a5
okay you see g i'm splaying these moves
all the time now this bishop on e6
ladies and gentlemen
it's not doing the most that it can do
can we put that bishop on a slightly
better square
let's do it can we put that bishop on a
slightly better square folks
we absolutely can let's centralize it on
d5
now one thing that i want to do here is
push this pawn to f4
in order to support this bishop on e3
and essentially the stage of the okay
again remember he wants to get his
knight to e5 can we prevent that
can we now stop him once again from
getting his knight to e5 while also
improving one of our pieces i mean you
can see that i'm playing very gradually
i'm not doing anything crazy
i am slowly marginally improving my
position to the maximum i'm pushing all
my pawns
up to good squares to support the pieces
and i am limiting the mobility of his
pieces
stopping them from getting to active
squares um
and eventually how am i going to win i'm
eventually going to start doing
something a little bit more active one
idea is to put this bishop on e4
try to take on d3 and take on b3 there's
a lot of ideas that i could employ here
to win the game
because i'm low on time i'm well i'm
going to play a little bit quickly here
but there's one more thing that i want
to do because it's an end game what is
the sort of textbook piece of advice
that is often shared in the end game
what is the textbook piece of advice
that's often shared in the end game what
do you kind of always have to bring your
king up
so i'm going to do that i'm going to
play lip service tonight even though in
a real game i wouldn't have gone king g7
i'm gonna show you guys that i care uh
about endgame principles and i'm gonna
get my king maybe to f6
maybe it's just a g7 so it you know so
it just stays ready for future action
uh now let's get this rook up to a nice
little square on e4
uh potentially i'm eyeing the maneuver
rook at four rook f2
but why did i play rook c8 i have 38
seconds
one more move i want people to find okay
so rooksy one was a blunder
but can somebody answer me that question
why did i play rook c what was i
preparing to do
yes i was preparing to break with c4 and
i'm actually still going to have a
chance to do that
why am i breaking with c4 well because
my pieces are more active than his
according to our principle that we've
formulated many times when your pieces
are this much more active than your
opponent's pieces
at some point you're gonna have to open
the position up and the more you open it
up strategically
the more the domination of your pieces
can be displayed
okay so everything i did hopefully makes
sense here i didn't do a single move
that was mysterious
everything was just simple improving my
pieces or
making my opponent's pieces worse either
both of these are the two sides of the
same coin
and that's how you play on games light
all right so we're just going to take
this guy
and we're going to try to trade the
rooks and promote the spawn force and to
give up this knight
boom now there's many ways of winning
this position uh but in the spirit of
uh preventing our opponent from doing
any shenanigans
what would we do we want to prevent
every single shenanigan here and he's
got only one source of shenanigans
that's the b-pawn
what would we have done rook b1 is
correct right now i know that my style
is crazy and i like
sacrifices but it's important to know
how to play like this too right in order
to develop a
sacrificial style you also have to
practice
essentially identifying and preventing
your opponent's ideas the boa
constrictor style that petrossian the
karpov is
is snowfall okay one moment please
well unholy soda hopefully that answers
the question a little bit
let us continue with another game and
you guys can see that
our opponents are are better now right
they're not they're not folding over and
dying easily but that doesn't mean
you know that we have to despair we just
have to apply our principles to a
greater extent once again some of the
guy plays h6
i don't get this move at all so we're
gonna repeat what we did in the previous
game
and uh already at this point uh i you
know i i said before that
that we have to accumulate our advantage
slowly but the moon bishop g4
specifically is a mistake
and the reason it is a mistake is as we
have discussed many times
it leaves these two pawns both
undefended and that can be exploited
with
one very typical move yep jason i
remember your request and so
i'm not gonna say i deliberately did
that but i had that in mind
maybe three is correct and uh he is in
huge trouble right out of the opening
and and this is why i recommend people
to study the opening because i didn't do
anything crazy here but
at my opponent's level he should know he
should know the stuff i mean he
shouldn't get into this kind of trouble
in seven moves in one of the most
conventional openings not not to like
give him
crap or anything but if you want to
learn from his mistakes
then um you know this can be very easily
avoided if you just
learn the basic theory of openings now
my opponent is actually playing this
quite well right he takes on f3 and he
takes on d4 thank you nichola for the
thousand bits
but i saw this right he is winning the
pawn back
if i take on d4 then he will take with
the knight and
uh his knight will be very active so
what should we do in order to limit the
activity of his knight
how do we use our pieces in order to
limit the the mobility and the activity
was that bishop d5 is the right idea but
not the best execution
there is a very similar way of doing
that right bishop b5 to pin his knight
uh and essentially immobilize and rook
b6 here would be a very strong move
let's see if he finds it and then we
will drop our queen to a4 in order to
reinforce
our pressure on the diagonal no these
guys are good i mean
uh again i don't mean to suggest that
these players aren't good they are
i'm actually very impressed with the
level displayed by some of these
uh some of these players and now we're
just going to take on d4 we are up upon
we are in great shape
and his position is essentially in ruins
uh
so let's see what he ends up doing here
black has ways that he can try to fight
and he does find one of them he plays d5
well he
he sort of he he he tries to open the
position up
and and this speaks to something that i
shared earlier which is that in such
situations
the best way to react is sometimes to do
nothing but to sort of
passively develop right and and i know
that you guys and i see that you guys
want to play knight c3 which i love
right you just develop it's okay the
blind knife thank you for the tier one
and
in a situation like this we just
continue developing
how do we continue developing with an
eye toward
supporting the pawn on t4 i don't want
this pawn uh to get to get weak let's go
bishop e3 bingo
okay let's castle along in order to tuck
our king and he's probably going to
castle short
and now well we have a situation of
opposite side castling
what does that mean that means we need
to start attacking
and we're going to do that with the very
typical move h4
i am playing with fire here i'm just not
expecting him to
well first of all i think that we're
playing well um
this is not necessarily my repeat i'm
not playing exactly how i would actually
play in a real game against the gm
because i'm also trying to emphasize
certain important themes
and the application of certain
principles i'm not trying to dumb it
down for anyone right that's not what
i'm doing
but what i am doing is i'm trying to
steer the game in certain directions
that may be more conducive to people's
learning uh than if i were to strictly
play in the way that i would play
against the ngo
okay now the time has come for us to uh
take
care of a couple of things right well
actually no the time hasn't come for
that yet
let's continue attacking what do we do
how do we continue attacking
he hasn't pinned himself by playing
queen e6 we should keep that in mind
he's unpinned his knight
but i don't really see where that knight
is going to go
so let's go h5 now e5 is the move that
most people are suggesting and i was
going to propose that move initially
but when you push a pawn in the center
you always have to ask yourself what the
drawbacks of that move are
and had we played e5 notice that we
would have weakened that f5 square and
his knight could have occupied that
square
and exerted pressure on both the bishop
and the d4
he's gotten rook to a8 that is a very
slow move it allows us to open up
the h-file clearly he wants to prepare
a6
but what he's not sensing is the time
right he's not sensing the fact that we
are so close to just checkmating and
thank you
big sweaty father uh for the sub to uh
ice cream overlord he sets a vicious
trap if we take on h6
we actually lose a rook does anybody see
how
if bishop takes h6 he takes we take on
h6
loose pieces drop off when you castle
long you have to pay special attention
to that position of the king on c1 he
has queen f4 so let's first play e5
in order to force this queen onto a
compromise square
and only then are we going to take on h6
that was a pretty vicious trap
i don't know if he said it consciously
or not but in any case that was pretty
impressive
uh but that's why we have to doubt
everything right we always have to
double check
we have to make sure that we're not
stopping the calculation pretty much
early and that we're actually checking
at every juncture for our opponent's
ideas right and so
that just has to be sort of an automatic
process okay now
a crucial question to ask yourself in
this position is he actually threatening
to capture on b5 is that a threat
is that a threat that is actually not a
threat
because 88 is gonna be hanging but uh
and
and follow me carefully here even though
it's not a threat
uh we have to be aware that he might
move his rook away
and uh after he moves his work away not
only is ab going to become a threat
but in addition to that if our bishop
moves away he's going to take on b2 so
what i propose folks is that we take
care of this bishop immediately
so that we can untie our hands we can
wipe our hands clean of this
and what does that allow us to do that
allows us then to repurpose our queen
from a defensive piece in a piece that
is mired in
in just crap on the queen side to a
piece that actually helps
in the attack now when i say helps in
the attack what do i mean
where does the queen be long if you
could point to any square on the board
here
where does the queen be long how do we
get it there it definitely belongs well
ultimately where does it belong
everybody's saying the correct move but
what i'm asking people exactly so h6 or
h7
one of those squares on the h file is
where the queen belongs
he's probably going to go rook b this
guy is playing probably like a 16 1700
and we are going to play one move b3
here to take care of the b
file pressure then we are going to
probably continue our plan with queen d2
clean h6
the other idea here the other way of
executing this very same
plan of putting something on the h file
can somebody tell me what i'm talking
about here
let's say that we did not want to move
our queen we wanted to keep our queen on
c2 in order to
protect uh some of these pairs what else
could we have done
we can exactly we can double up the
rooks now before we even double up the
rocks
i'm looking at this knight on c3 and i'm
saying there is a very very very juicy
outpost for this knight
this outpost will guarantee that he
doesn't have any shenanigans down that c
file
uh could we get that knight over to that
outpost exactly we get that knight over
the outpost c5 how did i find this move
well i asked myself what does he want
and i recognize that he probably wants
to play c6
and i don't like pins like this right i
don't like my queen and my king both to
be penned by
like a measly rook so by improving the
position of the knight
i'm able now to resort to revert back to
my original plan
and i'm actually just gonna keep my
queen on c2 so it just guards and
supervises that knight on c5 lends some
extra protection to it
and i'm gonna i'm gonna delegate the
task of checkmating him to my rooks
at least initially he goes a5 so he's
he's trying to execute an attack of his
own but as you guys can see my attack is
both faster and stronger
uh and it's going to lead to checkmate a
lot faster
again these games are are very
competitive i mean these players are
good
uh but at the same time i'm not doing
anything crazy i'm just sort of
playing typical attacking moves i'm
improving my pieces
and i'm winning the game
okay so
let's see what he does i'm going to
catch my breath
well that's the point of the speedrun
though i'm not trying to
suggest that it's easy uh but what i am
trying to suggest is that
most moves most people can make these
types of moves on a regular basis
and while chess mastery is a very
difficult process
uh this this this tendency to
by by some people to claim that it's
some sort of magic
uh in the direct sense of the word is
wrong uh there is logic that goes behind
every one of these moves and i'm trying
to at least partially
uh you know expose that logic and and
show what it looks like
if only to you know inspire some of you
to
to pursue this kind of master okay so he
resigns
uh yeah uh so in
polar bear bc five gifts it keeps me
going
and that's what keeps me going i
appreciated polar bear uh thank you for
the gift it's up to doe gator
to shigeru to jusco and craig and
knighting
samurai cocaine um
all right um so let me see we have
over 2 000 subs which is awesome and the
support has been unreal
well thank you guys i appreciate it yeah
this is definitely
uh you know demanding of energy but uh
it's the best kind of demanding and
to have people who appreciate me is is
honestly
amazing so uh it
let's get a first look at the first game
here with the king's gambit
now there's many ways to play against
the kings yeah but and
if you guys watch that old lesson i gave
to tori there is even the move c6 here
which i uh once showed to john davis
uh it is a very interesting and very
rare move it actually prepares d5 it's
kind of like a karo khan within a king's
gamut right
you guys have seen the karo khan so this
is kind of like the karo khan in the
king's gamut
uh you prepare the pawn break d5 so it's
a very interesting one
but in this game i decided to play very
simply right i open up the center
i get the knight over to to t5 and i
earlier mentioned uh
well i would recommend 100 end games you
must know that is one good book on
grand master on on theoretical endings
now this is the moment that i wanted to
focus focus on because
a lot of people would look at this and
say daniel aren't you giving up your
pawn
you had an extra pawn you're giving it
up why are you doing that
and this again allows me to reinforce
the concept of
transforming your advantage it is true
that our opponent sacrificed upon a move
too
but that creates for us a bargaining
trip we can use this pawn and we can
give it away strategically in return
for other advantages such as the fact
that he no longer has an attack against
our king
we have the two bishops which is a
tangible advantage
and we well it's not even compensation
it implies that you're down material
we're not down material
material is equal so here we can go c6
just defending that pawn
and staking a claim in the center we've
got the two bishops we have a very
comfortable position
i wouldn't say that black is better
necessarily but black is certainly very
very comfortable here because of the two
bishops
solid position and good development okay
so that is another thing you have
to make sure you understand about
gambits you can take that pawn
with the intention of ultimately giving
it away in return for other advantages
all right so in the game he
ended up not accepting that pawn for a
very long period of time and when he
finally did take it
he allowed me to take on d4 with my
queen and essentially force the trait of
queens now somebody asked i think
abdulrahman asked
why did he have to take the queen why
can't he just slide his king over and
basically force me to retain
my crappy pawn structure well can
somebody answer that question for me
what exactly is the reason behind yes
queen takes p2 i mean simply you take
the pawn and you're up another pawn now
black doesn't win a rook but
this is a very problematic i can even
return to d4
so this is all very straightforward
stuff ctxd4
rook b8 and at this point i just started
that end game campaign
i get my bishop to the best where i can
go to now this boa constrictor style
asking myself what my opponent wants and
preventing an f6
g6 literally just stopping this knight
from getting to any of these active
squares
it drives my opponent crazy right a5
stopping him from expanding
and eventually right look i'm just
sending every single piece away
rookie 8 against top 95 and now c5 to
cement the pawn on d4
and finally i'm preparing the decisive
pawn break c4 that's
some people ask like how do i actually
how do i actually
you know win the game when i do this
well you have to start looking for bond
breaks or you have to start looking for
ways to
actually start attacking your opponent's
king uh but here i decided that a pawn
break would be most fitting
because of how stretched out his
resources are
but he made the task quite easy for me
by just giving up a rook
or rather an exchange and now the pawn
break was even more effective because i
have two rooks to one i trade rooks
and he resigned so that's you know
that's how that game went and again here
he he essentially
killed his chances for the whole game by
playing h6 i mean
i just don't understand that move at all
because it doesn't even really prevent
anything
uh so it allows me to occupy the center
now the book queen b3 and he's already
in trouble right he's already in big
trouble
uh because f7 is hanging and b7
and honestly uh in this position i i
remember that i actually
missed a much stronger move i can
actually play a preliminary tactic
and only then take on v7 can anybody
actually
spot this tactic i miss this in the game
and this is actually theory i
remember this now
it's actually not d5 well d5 uh is a bit
counterproductive because the knight
moves away you plug
the diagonal it's bishop takes f7 good
job
queen takes f7 and the idea is that the
knight is now undefended
white is simultaneously attacking two
pieces and white is going to end up up
two pawns at the very least
so that would have been even stronger
than what i did but what i did was good
i mean i have huge pressure on his
position i went upon
and we get this opposite side castling
situation which often
means that you have to immediately start
attacking your opponent's king
because time is going to be very limited
and that's exactly what we do
we attack our opponent's king by opening
up the a trial we avoid
the move bishop takes h6 because that
would have plundered the rook
we first play e5 then we take the pawn
we don't take the pawn to win a pawn we
take the pawn to open up that h file
we clear it clarify the tension get the
knight an outpost double the rooks and
deliver checkmate on h7
yeah i mean not blundering this kind of
stuff takes practice right it takes that
sort of
metal detector if you will in your brain
that
that can only be built up through years
of training in a blundering like this
all right okay guys so that was i think
enough speed running for
this evening i'm feeling pretty drained
uh because these games were actually
pretty uh pretty rich you know they were
full of life
[Music]